what is making echo taught you about
yourself
and filmmaking put yourself first then
filmmaking
i think it was the longest
project i've ever done
in my life so i mean definitely
i don't look at schooling as a project
because it changes every quarter
so to speak
it was this um
competition that came out in me with
myself
[Music]
and it was
shattering a lot of naivete about
how hard this would be so
you have to have some very challenging
internal conversations with yourself
when you get disheartened
or when you feel alone in a process
even if you have a great support network
it's very easy to just
shut off it
there's there were rises and falls of
depression that were
uncontrollable because you just
get so exhausted with the process
um it taught me how to
stop also inside of my myopic
obsessive nature to finish or to get a
moment
perfect it taught me to stop to
enough is enough for a day like if we're
cutting we've been cutting for like 12
hours
or something it's like stop take a break
and i didn't know that about myself you
know
um taught me a lot about
health and taking care of yourself
before the shoot during
and afterward because you can you can
burn out before you start shooting
you can burn out pre-production and then
you get into production and you're
making
the most important decisions about a
performance or about coverage or about a
particular moment that matters
and you don't have the battery power to
keep going and that didn't really happen
to me
but i could feel it a couple of times
where i was like i am so
tired and i wasn't prepared for how
tired
my brain was going to be and
in the end of the day
i think it taught me that um
no one gives you anything when you get
to the top of the mountain
like no one gives you a trophy or uh
like a reward or a bottle of champagne
and formula one race
or whatnot you're you usually get to the
top of that mountain
in the dark alone and you have to
figure out that that is what you want it
all
you know i think at the beginning it can
be really romantic that when you finish
it's gonna you're gonna run through a
ribbon in a marathon or something
but it's a lot closer to what i've read
about some mountaineering expeditions or
some summiting
of some peaks where a climber got
somewhere in the dark alone
and no one was there and
you have to figure out what got you
there you know
a lot of people on the way giving you
support a lot of people in the way
um giving you nourishment a lot of
people in the way
helping you know you didn't get there
alone but sometimes you do land there
alone you finish alone
um and
and then i think i also learned that
the affair is over you know i think that
before you make a movie
there's an affair it's like a
romanticized idea
of the work and of um
um every part of the process you know
people think editing is easy it's the
opposite
you know people think that doing sound
mix is easy it's the opposite
um people think they can kind of get
away with doing a di
on like um you know their computer
i don't agree with that um and
so what happened also for me
was learning that the
love affair with
the idea of making a film was dead
and for a little while it wasn't
replaced with anything
it was just over and that didn't mean i
wanted to stop
doing this it meant that there was an
internal feeling of emptiness
and truth and
at the end of that there was a real
strong light at the tunnel and there was
uh like a
maybe a mature um
maybe a stronger sensibility of what
this really takes to do
and so then when i looked at my next
project
i looked at what needed to be fixed i
looked at how the script needed to be
polished and reworked
i looked at the production schedule i
immediately pushed production
off by a certain amount i needed more
time to do this right
and so i suddenly came at the sophomore
film the next film
i suddenly came at that film with a
sense of
um realism
not optimism and
love and not lust you know
and um one of the things i also learned
was that i have a very
um incredible wife
you know and our relationship went from
you know
having lots of passion and having lots
of lust and just being
so in love with each other and then when
we got married it became complicated and
super interesting
and better and richer and and the fabric
of everything
became stronger and is very synonymous
with my breath
my metaphor about the affair of making a
movie is over
and it becomes better and more
interesting i don't think you can rush
that
because i went through a lot of pain to
go from
feeling the affair to being in love with
this craft more than i ever have but i
had to go through
all of the darkness first and not
pretend
like i had done it before i think some
filmmakers
including myself years ago maybe
had a sense of feeling like i could do
it and it wouldn't be hard
and it's a different journey so
i learned how to tell myself the truth
more
yeah i don't remember the other question
wow i don't know if if it can top that
i'm just
what did um making echo teach you about
filmmaking
oh yeah sure sure uh what did
echo what did making echo teach me about
filmmaking yeah
um
it was a
opportunity to see strengths and
weaknesses
under a microscope right these are the
things i thought i was good at
these are the things i think i needed to
work on and when you take the duration
of your material
and when you take the audience's
investment in the material right
okay so they were going to be invested
in a 30-second ad or 60-second ad or
what have you right okay
so how much of that day is it taking how
much are they invested in watching this
content
okay so that's what that is and then
over here it's like they're gonna buy a
ticket to your movie and give you two
hours of their life
in a place that's not in their house and
that is a completely different
invitation
so it taught me a lot about the reality
of
okay this muscle this strength is solid
this is good i can keep improving that
and i'm going to challenge myself to do
that on the next movie and here's how
and then the the opposite is true which
is
i feel like this aspect of the story or
the script needed work
and it never got the right amount of
work and
it pisses me off but it didn't and
it got finished
and it's done so it's like you can
noodle with it forever
and you never ever finish it or you
finish it and you say
i gotta really be honest with myself
about that's gotta get fixed next time
it taught me a lot about as a
as a director it taught me a lot about
people
taught me a lot about expectations
and morale i
was reminded just before the save my ass
by the way
i was reminded just before we started
filming like a week before
uh my dad says you're the captain of the
ship
and i was like of course you know like
thank you and he goes i didn't mean it
like that i meant it like
you're the captain of the ship you are
the captain of the ship
things go right you're the captain of
the ship if things go wrong
you're the captain of the ship and
after four or five days um it became
super clear
that i needed to adapt
my leadership style to the team not
because they needed me to
or asked me to but because i was paying
attention to being the captain of the
ship
and whether that was to
make sure to every day in the morning
say good morning to every person on the
team
and at the end of the day tell every
person on a team great day
which i did do and i had already really
been doing that but it wasn't hyper
diligent it wasn't
as focused around you know what they're
working so hard every day and we're only
in or 15 or whatever it was and
okay great so that i needed i needed to
be a better leader
and um and then it also
uh taught me a lot about um editorial
i learned that i'm used to assembling
and cutting while i'm going
on ads and we didn't have that strategy
on this film and we are changing it
on the next film so for example
we shoot uh you know we shoot material i
look at some dailies
but i don't make editorial decisions the
editor's not on set working
and then when we're done and we're in
the can i look at everything
for a period of four weeks or whatever
and then we start assembling
i learned that that process was super
inefficient and
the results of that process was that or
the reason why it happened
was because we were working so fast
and so hard every day there wasn't time
to review material in earnest
and so that's going to change on the
next film and the next film we're going
to cut concurrently with the production
i read a lot about how that's done i
talked to a bunch of editors in
hollywood about how they do it
i followed the process or you know
really drilled in on the process the way
they cut munich
uh spielberg's film uh they they cut it
concurrently
and they were able to have a strong
assembly of the cut within i believe a
few weeks after
production and it also creates an
efficiency in any pickups
etc so probably one of the biggest
lessons i learned was about
editorial and the last thing i really
really learned about was
my passion for
meticulous cinematography
and very specific color grade work in
the di
is equal to my
level of passion for sound design in the
mix
you know i had had a lot of experience
in a di
for commercials but the mix on
commercials
is really quick they do it in a day it's
done you're not even usually there
and on a film the mix along with foley
and design and dialogue cleanup and
looping and stuff
you know this takes months and months to
do and
i fell in love with the sound design
process i fell in love with
uh the final mix making this weighted
ratio decisions on the audience's
experience from a sound perspective
and that was i've never had that
experience before so that was really
exciting
so um yeah i'm sure my answer to this
question could be like two hours long
you